que connaissez-vous du continent
africain que connaissez vous de ces
différents pays et différentes villes
que connaissez vous de ces différents
peuples et différentes cultures
que connaissez-vous de sa diaspora à
l'âge de 7 ans j'ai quitté mon pays
natal la côte d'ivoire pour aller vivre
avec ma famille au maroc
du haut de mes sept ans j'avais vraiment
hâte d'arriver au maroc
je me disais que ça n'allait pas être si
différent puisque je restais tout de
même sur le même continent
j'avais donc hâte de découvrir ce
nouveau pays et hâte de découvrir une
autre partie de mon continent
arrivée à casablanca bien qu'y voir yens
donc bien qu africaine j'étais quand
même autre autres à cause de ma couleur
de peau autres à cause de mon accent
français autres à cause de mes
références musicales ivoirienne
burkinabé malienne
puisque mon enfance a été bercée par
oumou sangaré ismaël isaac salif keita
ou encore aïcha koné mais malgré les
différences culturelles qui existent
entre le maroc et la côte d'ivoire
là bas les frontières sont fines et pour
des raisons historiques insignifiante
est fausse
donc les règles et coutumes se baladent
librement trouve le lien et ancrages où
bon leur semble s'affirmer se transforme
tout en gardant une base commune donc au
maroc
j'étais peut-être autres mais j'étais
toujours africaine et ça c'était ma base
commune
j'ai donc grandi avec deux perspectives
le couscous et le thé marocain le bissap
et la tchèque et poissons braisés
ivoirien l'hospitalité marocaine et
l'ambiance ivoirienne ces deux
perspectives m'ont permis de voir le
monde de différentes manières puisqu'en
chacune d'elles
j'étais incomplète j'étais là mais
seulement qu'à moitié
je suis resté dix années de ma vie au
maroc puis j'ai décidé d'aller
poursuivre mes études
loin très très loin du soleil des
palmiers la bonne température
une fois arrivé à montréal mon identité
s'est complexifiée identifié comme étant
autres au maroc
vous imaginez ce que je suis devenu hors
du continent
je vais vous le dire un enfant perdu ici
je vais partie de la diaspora africaine
je suis un fruit issu de ses diasporas
je suis made in africa je suis aussi
capricorne et j'ai cette ambition
7 ce besoin le questionner un statu quo
un statu quo qui prend la forme d'une
étiquette qui a été posé sur mon
identité à la minute même où mon avion a
décollé de l'aéroport mois médecin qui
s'est posé à celui de pierre elliott
trudeau made in africa oui mais pas
vraiment je vous explique lorsque j'y
vais au maroc on m'appelait l'ivoirienne
jusqu'à là tout va bien
quand j'allais en vacances en côte
d'ivoire on m'appelait la marocaine et
quand je vais en france à cause de ma
couleur de peau on m'appelle l'africaine
j'ai l'impression d'être ce jouet coquin
l'enfant le veut puisque personne ne
voit réellement l'utilité qui se cache
en lui les en soit je peux comprendre
je peux comprendre que cette identité ne
soit pas facile à assimiler à accepter
puisque en soi qu'est ce qui constitue
réellement une identité
on ne met que très rarement en valeur
cette singularité
cette identité diasporique complexe
certes mais riesch a tellement de
niveaux
cette identité qui se revendique ok lie
la diaspora africaine dépasse les
limites sociales du continent africain
elle est un atout à la fois pour le pays
d'origine est quelque part aussi pour le
pays d'accueil
je vais partager avec vous certains
secteurs au sein desquels cet aspect
date où s'illustrent plutôt bien parlons
mais rapidement d'économies j'aimerais
quand même pouvoir vous gardez ville
plus longtemps possible depuis ces dix
dernières années le nombre des personnes
de la diaspora africaine a
considérablement augmenté par la même
occasion le nombre des transferts de
fonds de ces diasporas là vers les pays
d'accueil des membres l'essai de
l'espoir ont eux aussi considérablement
augmenté ces transferts de fonds vont
directement dans les foyers évite donc
la corruption ils ont l'objectif
principal palier aux dépenses
quotidiennes aux dépenses primaires des
foyers bénéficiaires on parle ici des
dépenses liées au logement les dépenses
liées aux vêtements ou encore à
l'alimentation
pour donner un exemple en 2016 la
totalité des montants et du transfert
des transferts de fonds qui ont été
effectués des membres de la diaspora
africaine vers seulement l'afrique
subsaharienne était de 33 milliards de
dollars la même année
l'aide humanitaire internationale la
joute par des gros gabarits fmi-banque
mondiale et c était l 2 27 milliards de
dollars pour toute l'afrique entière il
ya quand même une différence
mais on ne sert pas seulement qu'à
envoyer des western union
je vous rassure du moins c'est ce que
j'aimerais croire nous sommes sont aussi
des ambassadeurs
nous sommes les premières personnes qui
nous introduisent à l'étranger on vous
introduit à de nouvelles façons de
penser de nouveaux modes de
fonctionnement de nouvelles croyances
sans que vous ayez à dépenser un centime
pour août billets d'avion l'identité
plurielle des membres de la diaspora
africaine facilite considérablement les
échanges interculturels l'immigration a
façonné le monde
certains pays ont donc profité de
différents codes étrangers pratiques
éthiques étrangères qui ont profité à
leur développement ne pas s'intéresser
au fait qu'en un seul individu on puisse
retrouver différents codes s'est rangé
différents pratiques éthiques étrangères
un dosage supérieur à celui d'un
individu lambda c'est quelque part
minimisé la richesse qui en découlent
certaines régions d'afrique
on l'entend été bercé par l'oralité les
histoires les coutumes les règles se
raconte et se raconte toujours
d'ailleurs de vive voix et il y à une
caste en particulier qui a le droit de
partager toutes ces informations
ce sont les conteurs et conteuses
traditionnels de l'afrique de l'ouest
les griots les griottes moi aussi quand
j'étais petite je voulais être griottes
je voulais chanter et raconter les faits
de ceux et celles qui avaient marqué
l'histoire à mon plus grand désarroi
ma grand mère m'a vite fait comprendre
que peu importe qu avait pu raconter
simone de beauvoir on ne devient pas
griller on et rions cette envie que
j'avais étant plus jeune s'est fortifiée
avec le temps lorsque je voyais dans les
médias des histoires fausses et des
narrations pessimistes qui mettait en
avant une afrique peu glorieuse les
africains constamment dans le besoin et
qui à ce qui paraît n'était pas assez
entré dans l'histoire
et c'est là que les ambassadeurs arrive
ces griots et griottes des temps
modernes ses membres de la diaspora made
in africa ils viennent vous parler de
leur pays de leur ville de leur culture
ainsi que de leurs peuples ils viennent
en dehors des frontières de leur pays
modifier la narration du continent
africain là où son blason a été salie
s'il ya bien une chose que j'affectionne
tout particulièrement c'est de regarder
des vidéos de qui montre une nouvelle
image du continent africain
une image plus glorieuse des indh et
vidéo qui met en scène deux jeunes
entrepreneurs issus de la diaspora
africaine qui sont en soif d'un
développement économique et social
récemment je suis tombé sur la vidéo
d'un jeune homme ivoirien d'origine
ivoirienne qui est né à rennes et qui a
grandi en bretagne il travaille dans le
domaine de la finance
c'est un jour décidé de de croire en son
rêve ivoirien
il est donc retourné en côte d'ivoire et
a décidé d'ouvrir une crêperie
mais pas n'importe laquelle en plus
d'avoir l'ambition de devenir une
franchise cette crêperie s'adapte aux
papilles gustatives de la population
locale sur le menu de ce jeune
entrepreneur on peut retrouver des
galettes à la loco des galettes
bretonnes avant
de la banane plantain ivoirienne en un
dessert ce jeune entrepreneur a réussi à
connecter faire coexister rallier deux
cultures deux montent deux pays que tout
semblait opposer en 2015 aux côtés de
quatre autres jeunes femmes
nous avons fondé sa diaspora une
plateforme qui vise à promouvoir une
meilleure image dans les médias des
femmes et de la jeunesse de la diaspora
africaine pour nom un an nous avons
voulu créer un espace en ligne ou la
jeunesse et la diaspora africaine
pourrait s'exprimer librement sur ce que
représente pour elle être un membre de
la diaspora africaine
un espace où cette jeunesse pour s
exprimer à la fois à son pays d'origine
et à son pays d'accueil la jeunesse de
nos jours se trouve sur internet
elle s'exprime merveilleusement bien en
140 caractères notre espace a donc été
en ligne mais comment arriver à
connecter toute une communauté dispersés
à travers le monde
comment arriver à connecter entre eux
des individus qui ne se connaissent pas
mais qui ont quelque part beaucoup de
choses en commun
la solution un hashtag en mots #dsk
expliqué une règle
partager une anecdote marquante ou en
l'état d'esprit en toute honnêteté nous
n'étions vraiment pas sûr de notre coup
mais à notre plus grande surprise le
hashtag a été repris plusieurs fois sur
différentes plateformes différents
réseaux sociaux
j'aimerais vous lire deux de hashtag qui
résume plutôt bien ce que je raconte
depuis tout à l'heure on voyage autour
du monde à la recherche de quelque chose
mais bien souvent c'est en rentrant chez
soi qu'on le trouve
#dsk speaking je suis d'ailleurs chez
l'étranger étrangères chez moi #dsk
speaking si on met cette singularité en
lien avec tous tes sort d'atouts que je
viens de vous citer on se rend vite
compte que c'est de jeunesse est alerte
aux paramètres qui constitue son
environnement la diaspora africaine et
la sixième région d'afrique
non pas parce que nous partageons une
une nationalité d'un pays africain non
pas parce que nos nos parents sont issus
du continent africain mais parce que
nous sommes et c est tout ce qui se
passe là bas nous touche ici puisque
nous sommes deux là bas nous sommes ici
à réécrire une narration à participer au
développement du continent
de loin l'idée serait qu'on arrive qu'on
puisse arriver du mois à capitaliser ses
compétences à travers différents
différentes structures adéquates qui
viendraient supporter les projets
initiatives des membres de la diaspora
africaine des projets qui pourquoi pas
pourrait venir créer un ton beaucoup
plus solide entre le pays d'origine et
le pays d'accueil
arrivé à capitaliser cette richesse
cette richesse économique culturel
intellectuel et
utilisé comme clef au développement
merci
[Applaudissements]